yeah so we're gonna switch gears a
little bit here and talk about having
tough conversations yeah when you're
scaling this is gonna come up over and
over again and Sam as a as a former
founder how do you handle tough
conversations with your team one of the
biggest things for us is just getting
out of the office and into fresh air and
of course this is you know if you feel
safe but we here at launch we go and
walk and talk so anytime anytime I have
a one-on-one with someone on the team
whether it's tough or not we actually
just go for a couple walks around the
block yeah which is really nice you get
exercise and also you don't feel number
one you don't feel like people maybe you
know overhearing what you're saying but
also it's just a nice kind of like a
objective atmosphere yeah and you can it
you know it's really good to
facilitating just really good
conversation and again it doesn't have
to be tough conversations but that's
what we do and then of course I would
recommend it for tough conversations
often times I don't think you know
founders will try to keep and
co-founders will try to keep the tough
conversations between themselves and I
think they forget that they've never
done this before in most cases so they
don't have all the answers so strongly
advice to seek outside help so you know
whether that's co-founder therapy
different you know advisers or investors
that you have HR reps there are plenty
of options for this so definitely seek
outside help because you know again most
co-founders don't have the experience
and other you know other people will
likely be more experienced than you yeah
we see this all the time where founders
come to us when it's reached a really
acute point and we're like well why
didn't you tell us two months ago yeah
we thought we could figure it out and
you know now the relationship is
impossible to repair or it's
significantly damaged and the company
may be damaged because they spent three
months fighting over their go to market
strategy or what their product was and
you're in a race against the clock in a
startup if you're debating stuff and
debating stuff and fighting about it and
there's bad feelings well that's time
you could have been putting into your
product or your go-to-market strategy or
understanding your customers better and
you're fighting with your co-founder
over I don't know the office layout or
the desks you're using or how you spend
money or should you be going to
conferences and a lot of times I find
that the
fights are almost universally four to
five times the fights are about things
that are not important to the ultimate
success of the business which is a wacky
yeah and a couple years ago I went
through a program called inner space and
we learned to not cross the net and what
that means is to imagine yourself on a
tennis court you're on one side your
co-founder whoever else is on the other
side and you want to make sure you're
not crossing over onto their side of the
net to you know speak for them or try to
you know communicate what you think
they're feeling
you only need to talk about and you know
mention what you're observing and don't
you know don't don't cross the net and
bring up things that you think that
they're observing right this is a
standard communication technique for
couples therapy family therapy instead
of telling people you think I'm stupid
or you don't think I'm hard-working you
would say I feel that you think I'm
incompetent do you and the other person
a chance to respond again oh I don't
think you're incompetent I wouldn't even
consider that crossing the net because
really you're you're going because
you're not saying what you've only
observed you're you're assuming that
they think you're incompetent but that's
an assumption so I want to say you know
I noticed that you were you know sending
me the you know well you sent me this
message the other day that said I was
incompetent so you wouldn't want to make
that assumption you'll just want to talk
about what you witnessed yeah no that's
sort of my point is like I you told me I
did a bad job on this that made me feel
that I am incompetent mm-hmm good do you
actually think I'm incompetent like
there's a way to say it and let the
person know you hurt your feelings that
gives them actually a little bit of
space because then they don't have to
deny it because they're like oh that's
how you felt when I said that that
wasn't my intent my intent was to be
candid like we talked about before and
transparent about the fact that hey you
know this product is not good enough our
NPS scores too low right and I like to
always police people speech when they
say I as supposed to we you know like we
need to get this done as opposed to you
or i right you know another point
to add to this is to just avoid
emotional confrontation so you know
unless it's time-sensitive or urgent
anytime you're feeling any sort of you
know anger or you know even if it's just
sadness just try to remove yourself if
you can you know maybe sleep on it you
don't want to be making decisions while
you're emotional so come back to it when
you can you know think about it
objectively yeah there's no reason to
fire off a slack this is where slack can
be problematic because some people can
start firing stuff off and slack yeah
and then emails almost as bad text
messaging is almost as bad like people
take the hardest conversations they
decide they're gonna do them on text
messages like text message not exactly
the place to have that discussion and
that might be a discussion best to have
on the phone or in person it's also very
hard to tell tone over pork yeah using a
phone or in person is always the
preferred method we've basically come up
with emojis as a way to try to and
animated gifs and memes to try to
mitigate against this so we're like oh
my god and I always use the facepalm
which was just like instead of me being
angry or frustrated I'm just like oh my
god because that to me seems like a
better way to communicate is Captain
Picard's how does that come across when
I do my Captain Picard
I do more of the facepalm it's sort of
like I used to facepalm sort of like oh
my god we still haven't gotten this done
or were like we're we're sort of
repeating our own incompetence and not
being able to solve this problem or
self-inflicted wound it's just sort of
like it's not like I'm angry at anybody
it's just more like frustration in the
system then I just want to put my head
in my hands and just be like why isn't
this still happening to us well why
isn't this result okay